le développement de la voiture
électrique stimule comme jamais la
filière mondial des batteries lithium
ion la production augmente rapidement en
chine notamment avec un peu de retard
toutefois aux états unis et en europe le
québec pendant ce temps là possède des
ressources minérales diversifiée et une
certaine expertise en recherche et dans
le développement et l'assemblage de
véhicules électriques spécialisé sera au
des présidentes directeur général de
propulsion québec c'est la grappe
industrielle des véhicules électriques
et intelligente du québec bon soir
bonsoir
alors dites-nous d'abord en quoi le
québec at il vraiment du potentiel le
potentiel d'occuper une plus grande
place dans ce marché qui est déjà très
très occupés par la chine nous présente
alors nous avons commandé une étude qui
a été réalisée par la firme kpmg pour
mesurer les chances du québec de tirer
son épingle du jeu dans ce marché
extrêmement compétitif tout d'abord nous
c'est nous qui avons les ressources
minérales dont vous avez parlé que sont
nécessaires à la production des
batteries
deuxièmement nous avons de l'énergie qui
quittent dont on peut s'approvisionner
questionnable qui est un très bon coup
en amérique du nord qui provient
évidemment de l'hydroélectricité nous
avons effectivement vous l'avez
mentionné une expertise dans les
batteries au québec notamment à
l'institut de recherche d'hydro-québec
donc nous avons le vraiment le tout une
combinaison d'atouts qui nous permettent
de se distinguer liée au fait que nous
sommes près des manufacturiers
automobiles américaines
donc ça c'est nos atouts et notre
expertise est ce qu'on a plus d'
expertise qu'ailleurs on a plusieurs
brevets dans les limites batteries des
véhicules électriques actuellement en
circulation dans le monde donc oui nous
avons définitivement une expertise nous
aurons besoin pour accomplir les
recommandations du rapport qui sont
notamment de mettre en place une usine
de cellules de batterie d'aller chercher
un partenaire étranger départements
stratégiques qui sont qui sont plus
avancés que nous le vraiment dans la
production des cellules par contre sur
les chimiques batteries sont de beaucoup
d'expertisé au québec donc ça nous prend
des partenaires vous avez identifiés
notamment une alliance avec un grand
groupe industriel pour le transfert
technologique
une alliance aussi avec un constructeur
automobile absolument on a besoin de ça
pour faire avancer notre industrie doit
être réalisée
un partenariat avec un constructeur
automobile c'est pas une condition
sinequanone ya plusieurs autres régions
dans le monde qui ont développé leurs
capacités de production sans prendre
entente dès le départ seulement on voit
là une opportunité notre proximité avec
les manufacturiers américains
ils doivent s'approvisionner doivent
trouver un approvisionnement stable pour
leurs batteries actuellement plusieurs
viennent de chine vous l'avez mentionné
considérant les relations difficiles
vacillante
j'ai dû rentrer les états unis et la
chine notre notre option pourrait
devenir le quelque chose de très
intéressant pour eux en tout cas très
certainement quand on regarde un
graphique qui se retrouvent dans l'étude
de kpmg
on voit clairement que c'est la demande
que la demande mondiale de batteries
lithium ion viendra essentiellement pour
le secteur de l'automobile électrique
c'est ça qui est incroyable regardez
l'évolution jusqu'en 2040 la dans les
projections tout ce qui tombe le palis
il le bleu royal c'est la progression
c'est pour le véhicule électrique y en
ait une partie pour le stockage
d'énergie mais c'est vraiment véhicules
électriques
on va aller chercher quelque part nous
dire ça en fait
d'abord les estimations laquelle vous
démontrer ici sont dus à plusieurs
s'explique de plusieurs façons les
incitatifs des différents gouvernements
pour l'achat de véhicules électriques
évidemment la la conscientisation à
l'urgence climatique donc il ya
plusieurs les récents développements
technologiques les véhicules ont plus
d'autonomie donc les gens vraiment
adopte le véhicule électrique
les scénarios les plus optimistes
estiment qu'en 2040 on arme ultime
départ 26 la demande donc alors
évidemment de demandes sur les batteries
et donc une demande sourit à les
minerais et c'est là qu'on peut tirer
notre épingle du jeu parce que c'est
nous qui les avons dans le sous-sol du
québec nous pouvons décider de les
exporter tout simplement nous ne pouvons
décider de les transformer ici et d'en
tirer les bénéfices économiques et donc
les transformer c'est une possibilité
absolument recycler au sous sol humain
on part d'une
d'une industrie du recyclage de
batteries lithium-ion qui pourraient
être développés tout à fait c'est une
industrie qui est très très qui est
émergente à ce moment ce qui est peu
développée pourquoi parce qu'il est
patent de véhicules électriques qui sont
à l'étape de la fin de vie qui sont
acquis on rompt besoin d'être recyclés
dans les batteries auront besoin d'être
inscrit donc qu'il ya définitivement une
opportunité à saisir
prendre un leadership pour mettre en
place des réseaux de collecte de ces
batteries là et de les recycler ici il
ya un grand bassin au canada et dans le
nord-est américain dont on pourrait
tirer profit une fois recyclées ses
batteries là elle offre des nouveaux
minerais finalement c'est comme une
nouvelle mine c'est un nouveau gisement
où on ne peut pas finalement à assumer
tous les coûts d'extraction
donc on peut les réintégrer dans notre
processus de fabrication de batteries et
là vous demandez quoi au gouvernement
parce que vous souhaitez qu'on
accompagne les producteurs de minerai on
parle souvent de nemaska lithium de 9
ans le gouvernement doit investir
beaucoup d'argent
le gouvernement aujourd'hui par
le biais de son ministre de l'économie
qui était présent au dévoilement de
l'étude a donné à investissement québec
en mai d'avec leur début d'émission
également donc donné un manque
d'investissement québec de trouver la
façon de mettre en oeuvre ces
recommandations là évidemment il ya un
accompagnement pour les producteurs de
des ressources premières pour qu'elles
pour que les résultats finalement de
leurs productions soient amenés ingrat
de batterie on a du lithium mais on a
aussi du graphite on a aussi du nickel
au québec tout et tout des ressources
qui sont nécessaires dans la production
des batteries à ce moment si elles ne
sont pas toutes au grade batterie donc
un accompagnement le pour vraiment
pouvoir finalement faire une intégration
verticale qui bob bénéficier à
l'ensemble de l'économie québécoise
c'est à dire qu'il ya toutes les étapes
de production et de transformation qu'on
soit l'heure exacte entraînements et
qu'on puisse en tirer profit
sarah houde merci beaucoup merci merci
bien